hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 6 of
books seven of his Nicomachean ethics
Aristotle says something that a lot of
people might have some some trouble with
today and plenty of people in his own
time criticized him for it has to do
with anger and it has to do with what we
call a cross or lag or loss of
self-control it's possible to lose one's
one's self control with respect to anger
I think this is something all of us have
experienced at one time or another at
least of being on that the broad side of
it many of us from from actually being
on the other side of it where we lose
control en Aristotle says that this is
in many respects better it's he's not
saying it's something good but he's
saying it's something less bad than
losing control of oneself at least with
respect to the main things that that
lack of self-control pertains to that is
the bodily desires for safe food and
drink or four for sexual pleasure so he
says it essentially less shameful I
Scott it's feminine there because
achrafieh itself as a feminine word so
you know this this like I said this is
thing that too many seems paradoxical
isn't it worse to lose control with
respect to anger because think about how
damaging anger can be and how anger
appears and you know we could go through
all sorts of stuff Aristotle didn't
himself on the scene take a lot of heat
for it but a lot of people following him
in the ancient world attacked him on
this particular point with respect to
any of these so that they said that
you're actually getting anger more of a
past then you should but Arizona has
some arguments for why he thinks that
losing control with respect to anger not
being an angry person all the time but
but losing control in a particular
situation can be less shameful the first
thing that he says which is quite
interesting and gives rise to something
quite memorable that anger is like a
hasty servant that's the sort of
catchphrase a hasty servant doesn't
stick around and listen to the whole
explanation about what it is if they're
supposed to do they hear the first thing
go cut the grass and they don't listen
to the person saying well now when you
do cut the grass make sure that it's
about this tall and leave the back field
alone instead they they just go rush off
and start implementing whatever it is
that they think that person meant is so
they get things wrong they only listen
to half of the instructions if that now
this means according to Aristotle that
anger listens to reason in a certain way
reason is this higher part of ourselves
better than say the appetites for sense
pleasures and so this means that you
know anger is actually engaging the
higher part of ourselves it's just doing
so in a way that's a bit mixed up so
what can we say about this how is it is
anger actually following reason well
what happens when a person gets angry
is they perceive some sort of threat or
they perceive some sort of transgression
and without actually checking whether
that is the case or not they immediately
engage in a reasoning process which goes
along these lines oh I have been
attacked I should not put up with them
instead and I should seek some sort of
retaliation and so it's right for me to
get angry this as part of what the
feeling of anger consistent and I'll get
that SOB at the end of my reasoning
process so it is a reasoning process but
it's one that's going straight it could
in fact be the right thing to do but the
angry person often is not checking
whether it's the right thing to do but
he says it's still better it's less
shameful because what what is yielding
to is something better reason not to at
the thumb iya desire for having sex
desire for eating you know ones fill and
beyond the desire for physical
intoxicants these sorts of things that
Aristotle considers to be in some
respects more shameful and less rational
so because anger is like a hasty
servants and follows reason in some way
it is less shameful that's the first
argument the second argument is that
anger and it uses two terms there that
we often find an air cells work or ghee
and foo Mo's both of which one time or
another we'll use for anger these are
more natural than desire in certain
respects why because just look at it you
can observe little children and nearly
all of them get angry about something
you know take their toy away see what
happens there they're angry animals feel
some sense
through most right there they may not
get upset about politics or or you know
comparing themselves against other
people in performance reviews but they
do get angry when you transgress certain
things that they feel to be limits and
aircel is a very funny case they'll tell
you about in just a moment started to
illustrate this he says it is more
natural than desire for excessive
pleasures so there are natural pleasures
like those of eating and drinking but
it's it's excessive for you to eat
thirds at every single meal and then I
have two desserts on top of that or to
be like a hobbit and have second
breakfast every day right I presumably
the hobbits of high metabolism but for
those of us who don't that would be
excessive likewise with with drinking or
with you know other intoxicants besides
alcohol perhaps a certain amount is
within limits and is good for you but
then you can go and get yourself
completely stinking drunk and that would
be in Aristotle's view excessive then
that would be shameful so if you're
desiring to get drunk all the time
that's more problematic than than
feeling anger and losing control with
respect to anger unnecessary pleasures
things that we don't actually need but
we become you might say in certain ways
almost addicted to and yes I understand
that addiction in the true sense is a
sort of a compulsion we're using this in
a very loose sense here the sense that
we use in our in our own society there
are many things that are not originally
pleasant to us but then after time they
become Pleasant we appreciate them and
we can have the laugh of self-control
with respect to them the Aristotle says
that's worse than lack of self-control
with respect to anger the funny example
that he gives is of a man who's angry
with his father and drags him outside
the door physically up to if I remember
right like the boundary post
of the the property and people are
saying hey what's wrong with you what
are you doing and he says hey that's
exactly how far he used to drag his
father so it's okay for me now Arizona
is not saying it's okay for anybody but
it is still saying it's less shameful to
being to be giving in to something that
seems to be so natural a effect sort of
emotional response within us another
another thing that he says though that
is quite an interesting argument is that
anger is not crafting anger doesn't
conceal anything we're rather is open in
the word he uses there's five of us
meaning that it shows itself when a
person is angry they're they're not as
we say pussyfooting around or you know
cutting they're not they're not candy
coating anything they let you know that
they're angry whereas people who are
trying to pursue pleasures quite often
they're not telling you exactly what's
going on think about you know what's
going on with with seduction right
you're trying to seduce somebody you
don't go straight up to them and say hey
wanna you know jump in the sack now we
could go through all these other
machination right and perhaps you know
that everyone knows that that's what
that really means but Aristotle thinks
that there's something to being upfront
to being as we say above the board being
you know straightforward about things
that any returns to him now you might
make an objection and say well what
about people who conceal their anger he
in fact talks about that in terms of
vices of anger here we're only talking
about losing self-control with respect
to anger where a person has you know
some sort of momentary lapse or tennis
they have those sorts of lapses and that
tends to be something quite open so if
we think that
openness is a good thing or sincerity
perhaps maybe there's something to that
hard the last argument that he provides
here is that acting it anger causes pain
to the person who is angry and he
contrasts this against hubris which the
grease used you know those who are used
to Greek tragedy think in terms of like
hubris being this you know tragic flaw
of reaching too high and you know
failing the process but the Greeks use
this to cover quite a lot what we would
nowadays called bullying is a matter of
hubris you know try to hurt somebody
else or impose something on them and you
do so because it provides you with
pleasure another way of thinking about
it is what we call sadism so you know
the saint is and the angry person both
may engage in aggression but the angry
person is not doing it with the intent
of you know just hurting the other
person so that they can get some
pleasure on but the angry person is
doing it because they have a desire for
retribution now they will get some like
but just pleasure here because they will
get some pleasure out of retribution but
it quite often this is painful to not
only be angry but to be acting on Inger
and many people who are angry say that
they don't get any pleasure out of you
know the vindication or retribution at
the end which again it for Aristotle is
a sign that it is less shameful notice
that Aristotle is not at all saying that
anger losing control with respect to
anger is a good thing he's not saying
that at any point of this he's just
saying it's less shameful than losing
self-control because of one's desire for
physical pleasures